OUT BY UKRAINE.
THE DRAMATIC RAID IN A MINSK
HOTEL IS ALL OVER STATE TV.
SPECIAL FORCES SHOWN ARRESTING
THIS GROUP OF ALLEGED RUSSIAN
MERCENARIES, EXPERIENCING
FIGHTERS IS HOW THEY WERE
DESCRIBED SUSPECTED OF BEING
SENT BY MOSCOW.
WE GOT CONFIRMED INTEL THAT
THESE RUSSIANS HAD REAL COMBAT
EXPERIENCE AND ACTUALLY TOOK
PART IN ARMED CONFLICTS.
HEAVILY DISGUID POLICE
COMMANDER SAID AT THE TIME.
WHY HE DIDN'T KNOW WAS WHY THIS
MYSTERIOUS GROUP OF RUSSIANS WAS
REALLY THERE.
UNTIL NOW.
NOW WE'RE NOW DRIVING TO AN
UNDISCLOSED LOCATION ON THE
OUTSKIRTS OF KIEV, THE UKRAINIAN
CAPITAL WHERE WE'RE SET TO MEET
A GROUP OF FORMER MILITARY AND
INTELLIGENCE OFFICIALS WHO HAVE
AN EXTRAORDINARY STORY OF WHAT
ACTUALLY WENT DOWN IN BELARUS
AND HOW THEY WERE PART OF A
UKRAINIAN-LED STING OPERATION TO
CAPTURE SUSPECTED WAR CRIMINALS
TO BRING THEM TO JUSTICE HERE.
THE FORMER HIGH-RANKING OFFICERS
SPOKE TO CNN ON CONDITION WE
SHIELD THEIR IDENTITIES.
THEY'RE NOT AUTHORIZED TO
DISCLOSE DETAILS OF WHAT THEY
SAY WAS AN AMBITIOUS TOP SECRET
PLAN BACKED BY THE UNITED STATES
THAT FAILED AT THE LAST MOMENT.
WHEN YOU SAW ALL THOSE PEOPLE,
THOSE RUSSIAN MERCENAIES BEING
ARRESTED IN BELARUS, THAT WAS A
NIGHTMARE FOR YOU.
WHAT DID YOU THINK?
>> THE FEELING I GOT WAS VERY
BAD BECAUSE IT MEANT ALL OUR
HARD WORK WENT DOWN THE DRAIN.
WE PREPARED FOR MORE THAN A YEAR
IN HOPES THAT JUSTICE WOULD
PREVAIL.
UNFORTUNATELY, THIS DIDN'T
HAPPEN.
>> WHEN HE SAYS "BANDITS" HE
MEANS RUSSIAN-BACKED FIGHTERS.
AMONG THEM, A RUSSIAN NATIONALS
ACCUSED OF INVOLVEMENT IN THE
SOME OF THE WORST ATROCITIES OF
THE WAR.
IN 2014 A MALAYSIAN AIRLINER
MH-17 THAT KILLED 300 PEOPLE
ONBOARD.
OUR INTELLIGENCE FORCES SAY THE
MEN DETAINED IN BELARUS HAS BEEN
IDENTIFIED AS HAVING SUSPECTED
LINKS TO WAR CRIMES.
>> THERE WERE TWO WHO WERE
PRESENT WHEN THE MISSILE WAS
LAUNCHED.
FOUR OTHERS WERE MEMBERS OF A
GROUP RESPONSIBLE FOR SHOOTING
DOWN OUR MILITARY AIRCRAFT AND
KILLING AT LEAST 70 OF BEST MEN,
SO IDENTIFYING AND PUNISHING
THESE PEOPLE WAS OF HIGH
INTEREST TO US.
>> Reporter: IT WAS APPARENTLY
OF INTEREST TO U.S.
INTELLIGENCE, TOO.
ALTHOUGH, U.S. OFFICIALS DENY
HAVING ANY DIRECT ROLE.
ACCORDING TO OUR SOURCES, THE
UKRAINIAN-LED OPERATION GOT SOME
U.S. CASH, TECHNICAL ASSISTANCE
AND ADVICE FROM THE CIA ON
DRAWING RUSSIAN MERCENARIES IN.
A U.S. OFFICIAL TOLD CNN THOSE
ALLEGATIONS ARE FALSE.
BUT IDENTIFYING THE RIGHT PEOPLE
AND THEN LURING THEM OUT OF
RUSSIA REQUIRED AN ELABORATE
DECEPTION.
SO OUR FORMER UKRAINIAN MILITARY
INTELLIGENCE SOURCES TOLD US
THEY SET ABOUT CREATING A FAKE
PRIVATE MILITARY COMPANY WITH
ITS OWN RUSSIAN LANGUAGE
WEBSITE.
ON IT IT ADVERTISED JOBS LIKE
ONE LUCRATIVE CONTRACT OF $5,000
A MONTH TO PROTECT OIL
FACILITIES IN VENEZUELA.
THAT WAS THE BAIT WE'RE TOLD
HUNDREDS OF RUSSIAN MERCENARIES
ACTUALLY TOOK IT.
ALL THEY HAD TO DO, ACCORDING TO
OUR SOURCES, IS PROVE WHO THEY
WERE AND WHERE THEY FOUGHT.
>> WE STARTED TO CALL THEM AND
SAY, HEY, MAN, OKAY, TELL ME
SOMETHING ABOUT YOURSELF.
MAYBE YOU ARE NOT REALLY A
FIGHTER.
MAYBE YOU ARE A PLUMBER OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
AND THEN THEY STARTED TO REVEAL
THINGS ABOUT THEMSELVES, SENDING
US DOCUMENTS, MILITARY IDs AND
PROOF OF WHERE THEY HAD FOUGHT,
AND WE ARE LIKE, BINGO, WE CAN
USE THAT.
>> Reporter: THEY'RE SENDING YOU
EVIDENCE OF WHO THEY ARE.
>> YES, THEY SENT IT TO US,
ABSOLUTELY.
>> Reporter: IN FACT, WHAT
FOLLOWED WAS, ACCORDING TO OUR
SOURCES, A FOUNTAIN OF FREELY
VOLUNTEERED INTEL.
NOT JUST DOCUMENTS AND PHOTOS
BUT POTENTIALLY INCRIMINATING
PHOTOS LIKE THIS ONE OF A
MILITARY AIRCRAFT IN THE EASTERN
WAR ZONE OFFERED UP BY THE
FIGHTERS THEMSELVES.
ALL UKRAINIAN INTELLIGENCE HAD
TO DO WAS PICK THE ONES IT
WANTED OFF THE CONTRACTS BECAUSE
OF COVID-19 TRAVEL RESTRICTIONS
IN RUSSIA, THEY SENT THEM TO
BELARUS TO FLY OUT.
INTELLIGENCE SOURCES SAY THE
REAL PLAN WAS TO LAND THEM IN
UKRAINE AND MAKE THE ARRESTS.
>> IF THESE PEOPLE WOULD HAVE
ENDED UP HERE IN UKRAINE, THE
DETAILS OF THEIR CONTRACT ACTS
WOULD HAVE BECOME KNOWN AROUND
THE WORLD.
UKRAINE COULD HAVE BROUGHT THEM
TO JUSTICE AND SHOWN THAT OUR
FIGHT WITH RUSSIA IS SERIOUS AND
THAT WE WON'T RAISE OUR HANDS
AND SURRENDER.
>> Reporter: BUT THE PLAN FAILED
WHEN THE BELARU ARRESTED THE
RUSSIANS HOURS BEFORE THEY WERE
SUPPOSED TO LEAVE.
COULD HAVE BEEN A STUNNING BLOW
TO MOSCOW.
INSTEAD, ACCORDING TO OUR
SOURCES, A GOLD UKRAINIAN
INTELLIGENCE OPERATION WAS
FOILED.
THE UKRAINIAN GOVERNMENT TRIED
TO PUT DISTANCE BETWEEN WHAT
UNFOLDED LAST YEAR.
THE COUNTRY'S INTELLIGENCE
OFFICIALS HAVE NOT YET RESPONDED
TO OUR REQUESTS FOR ANY COMMENTS
ON THIS FAILED STING.
BUT EVEN IF THIS OPERATION HAD
TO SUCCEED AND SO MANY RUSSIANS
HAD BEEN TAKEN INTO CUSTODY, I